[Music]
clapping for doctors and nurses for many
a matter of the heart
thousands of people gathered at their
balconies and windows to applaud the
frontline workers when the virus swept
across europe in spring 2020
but all that applause doesn't help to
make ends meet
in many places around the world
healthcare workers are taking to the
streets they demand better working
conditions and better pay for their
often dangerous work
more than 120 000 nurses and care
workers have already died of kovit 19
worldwide
[Music]
welcome to govid19 special i'm monica
jones good to have you with us
well from superstar to afterthought
that's how millions of healthcare
workers must feel these days no more
clapping and certainly no celebrity
paycheck
at least a special tribute to frontline
workers in south africa our
correspondent reports from cape town
over the last 17 months we survived just
barely as an orchestra we couldn't have
live concerts today's the first live
concert that we can have
in the outdoor we think it's very
important to say to the medical workers
of south africa we see you we hear you
we honor you we thank you they have to
go through the trauma of seeing every
die every day people dying
and and help south africans so this is
basically to say thank you
so
[Music]
we are very grateful
if we can get some entertainment here
because with covert everybody's morale
is low so this is some upliftment for
staff and patients as well the pandemic
in general has been really tough i think
in every aspect emotionally physically
mentally as well um but like like i said
as well like we've been receiving a lot
of support
whether it's a free coffee or a free
concert from an orchestra
it really does help boost the morale as
well as we bond together it really helps
knowing that we're not alone i haven't
seen so many staff outside in the last
18 months so it is absolutely amazing i
would like them to sing every day
it will be a good thing
south africa is slowly emerging from a
third wave of infections the staffie has
been working in crisis mode for months
and while many here are happy about this
concert and this appreciation some are
also demanding more structural changes
to improve their working conditions
we do really work hard and more
appreciation would be like
a very wise thing to do because
we are the ones who are more exposed to
all things that are happening out there
so like so otherwise i can say yeah more
appreciation in that way and in so many
ways just to show that they appreciate
what we're doing healthcare workers do
definitely need more acknowledgement so
aokai is more money for our staff
because they work extremely hard and we
all need all across the world it's the
same phenomena we need more staff to
look after our patients around about 150
positive patients in the hospital today
we have seen that number decreasing over
the last few days which is a good sign
for us like i said we have to still
stick to the precautionary message
well free concerts are nice but it'll
take more to compensate health workers
for the incredible job they're doing
especially now during a pandemic well
let's bring in howard carton the ceo of
the international council of nurses in
geneva good to have you with us howard
and i know you've just visited rwanda
where you had the chance to meet nurse
leaders from several african countries
what did they tell you about their work
on the ground and and how they cope with
it all
uh very good to be with you uh look
nurses across the continent of africa
they're tired they're exhausted uh like
nurses in many parts of the world but
what i was struck by was that they are
feeling
more vulnerable
more at risk because of the slow rollout
of vaccination programs across the
continent
in high-income countries you know we've
got vaccination rates of populations at
60 70 80 percent it's
2
or less in many african countries and
then you delve into what that means for
health care workers and we've done some
work which has identified that there
could be like a third of healthcare
workers who are still waiting to
be vaccinated so whilst they've heard
the promises of yes we'll prioritize
you there'll be vaccines that will be
shared they're not seeing the reality of
that and that makes them fearful that
they're going to get
sick that there are risks to their
family and we know tragically that some
nurses have already died as a result of
contracting corona virus and more at
risk you know in the last few days we've
seen a billionaire take a healthcare
worker
into space but here on planet earth we
are still
not vaccinating all of our health care
workers and that to me should be our
absolute priority and of course in order
to make to make matters worth worse in
in rich countries including germany all
over europe there are quite a lot of
healthcare workers who refuse to get
vaccinated even though there is enough
of the vaccines around
other than that
how does the situation africa's health
sector compare to that in europe when it
comes to the situation of nurses or
doctors or staff
so
health systems in africa
on the whole don't have the same level
of funding and investment as in some of
the high income countries of of course
and that presents
challenges particularly for health care
workers for for nurses it's about not
having enough
staff we went into this global pandemic
with a shortage of six million nurses
across the world but that shortage
wasn't spread
evenly it's concentrated in lower income
countries we think about almost 90
percent of global nursing shortages are
on the are in lower income countries
including africa but what we're seeing
now which is really a worry is that
high income countries who've got
shortages are looking to countries in
africa to recruit to address their
shortages and they're saying it's okay
to recruit because there are nurses who
are unemployed in countries uh like
kenya for example that's true there are
unemployed nurses but when you dig a
little deeper it's because there isn't
the funding to employ those nurses but
there is clearly the health needs of the
population who need more nurses this is
this is this is complex but again it's a
an issue we need to be addressing
globally in order to get out of this
pandemic so healthcare workers all
around the world were applauded uh but
they're still stuck with bad pay that's
not really an incentive for young people
to get into this line of profession
look nurses are not super human yes they
are doing extraordinary work but they're
ordinary people like you like me they
are looking to be protected and safe at
work to be valued to be respected to
have fair reward to have career
opportunities it's not how loud the
world claps or how big the promises that
politicians make are it's delivery on
the ground both to recruit next
generation and to retain the valuable
staff that we currently have
howard captain the ceo of the
international council of nurses thank
you so much
thank you
time for one of your questions now and
as always our science correspondent
derek williams is here to offer an
answer
can the virus be transmitted by an
insect like when a mosquito bites you
the answer to this question we're quite
certain is no but what makes the
question really interesting
is why the answer is no and how
scientists came to that conclusion
because the answer to the question might
just as easily have been yes right i
mean after all
there's a long list of nasty diseases
that are mosquito-borne
first and foremost among them malaria
which is caused by single-celled
parasites from the plasmodium group
but mosquitoes can also
transmit a number of dangerous viruses
among them those that cause
yellow fever or zika or west nile fever
but other horrible pathogens like the
ones that cause hiv or ebola for example
and sars kobe 2 they are transmitted
mostly from human to human they aren't
carried by biting insects like
mosquitoes so why
well it comes down to whether or not the
insect can itself be infected
when it bites someone who's infected
with a disease-causing pathogen the
blood that a mosquito swallows of course
enters its digestive tract which
naturally has
multiple defenses to prevent the
mosquito from being infected by its
dinner
to be passed on by the insect
the pathogen has to overcome those
defenses then it has to to replicate
inside of the mosquito and then it has
to reach its salivary glands
in sufficient numbers to infect a new
host
and not every virus can manage that um
it requires evolving a highly specific
set of abilities a flurry of studies
early in the pandemic showed that
like other closely related coronaviruses
soros cov2 apparently can't replicate in
insects
which led healthcare authorities to
heave a huge sigh of relief
because they transmit so many deadly
diseases mosquitoes kill more humans
every year
than any other animal out there but at
least they aren't making the covet 19
pandemic any worse
[Music]
and finally the pandemic has taken a
heavy toll on tango culture because the
dance requires close physical intimacy
but
there are signs the dramatic argentinian
dance is making a comeback the buenos
aires tango world cup is in full swing
following kovid 19 health protocols and
with reduced capacity dancers from 25
countries will go cheek to cheek in two
categories salon style and stage style
competitors will be able to participate
in person and virtually
and that's all thanks for watching
[Music]